bonjour je suis gérant descendant de
contrôle technique et à la Réunion et je
possède 400 je suis gérant de centre
depuis 96 le nombre de PSN qui
travaillent dans le centre de contrôle
technique se compose ainsi 10 personnes
comme contre la technique et 5 PSN comme
administratif il y a 124 points de
contrôle technique qui serait parti sous
le soubassement et le tour de la voiture
et puis il a été ailleurs de la voiture
et puis l'intérieur du moteur et tout et
surtout le froid énorme la lumière et
tout il y a 35 points qui sont soumis
contre visite et les autres on est
obligé de mentionner le client est
responsable de sa voiture il faut que sa
voiture roule en bon état sur la route
c'est pour ça il y a le contrôle
technique
on est sur notre site de Saint-Louis je
recherche un mécanicien motivé avec
expérience ou sans expérience
avec espaillance s'il a un CAP un BEP ou
une formation professionnelle avec le
parc professionnel on n'a pas besoin
d'espérer mais attention il faut
quelqu'un de très motivé pour suivre une
formation en métropole c'est pas change
gagner même que vous avez le bac et
c'est assez confront même voilà il faut
faire et 175 heures en métropole et puis
revenir ici pour faire des heures de
formation de nos centres de contrôle
technique le temps d'acquérir un peu
d'expérience pour faire le contrôle
technique
le mécanicien contrôle technique doit
avoir de bonnes connaissances en
mécanique diesel et sens électrique
faire preuve d'un esprit d'analyse et de
synthèse
maîtriser les technologies informatiques
avoir une présentation soignée
être dotée d'un excellent contact
clientèle
le conseil que je pourrais donner au
futur candidats qu'il a un bon profil
qui s'est présenté devant les clients
pour être sérieux et tout pour
travailler dans le centre de contrôle
technique motivé sur ça le conseil que
je donne